ça détecte le mensonge grâce à la voix
le voice ici là 1 1 1 2 1 est ce que
vous voulez tester juste le détecteur de
mensonges pour voir si ça marche on va
faire un petit test par exemple voilà je
posais une question à quelqu'un qui lit
venez donnez moi la jours lorsqu'on est
devant mais tellement pas s'il vous
plaît mettez le truc derrière merci
vous allez voir voilà tout de suite si
le détecteur de mensonges et fiable
kelly
avez vous compris comment ça marche et
oui
mater les musées
[Rires]
c'est bon c'est sans mâcher ses mots
tout est donc alors franchement c'est
vrai alors ça marche très bien où il ya
une catastrophe c'est toutes les épouses
ont acheté ça pour passer l'appareil
détecte c'est vrai et inversement bien
l'entendre et inversement proportionnel
evelyne thomas
vous avez posé les questions vous allez
tous me poser des questions ici très
évident vous avez vous mettre la
question vous est posée l'émission à
n'importe quel moment
ok j'y répondrai avec la plus grande
franchise autre histoire
c'est dire mais j'avais de sanctions se
dire hors énergie
les jours des trois quarts charte sert
il
sur un certain camionnette au numéro du
beh nice alors mon cher sert il faut
bien que le mettre devant parce que ça
détestable
est-ce que vous jouez de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité dit de je le
jure wallah nardi
[Musique]
j'avais une première question moi c'est
cyril frionnet
savez-vous déjà coûté bien l'acquérir
avez vous déjà angolais
un employé tourine erreurs que vous avez
vous-même commises
on peut répondre oui savoir qui est ce
alors y en a plein
cette personne est sur le plateau dokoui
la bonne excuse je m'en excuse
bon je vois que comme c'était pas prévu
dans la séquence il faut continuer
deuxième question cyril avez vous déjà
refusé de prêter de l'argent à un ami
oui oui mur
il n'a pas en disant que vous n'aviez
rien sur wii
alors que vous en aviez plein oui déjà
des réponses avec la plus grande
franchise au sénat c'est terrible oui je
t'aime c'est la vérité vous envoie non
ils sont il a jamais su ils entendaient
bien normal ça boit voilà une troisième
question avez vous déjà volé quelque
chose à l'un de vos chroniqueurs
non voilà y'a rien à voler c'est vrai
nom c'est la vérité mensonge en anjou
les états unis ne se trompe
je refais est ce que peut-être j'ai
parlé de sujets il faut dire oui ou non
pas il donc
abonnez vous déjà volé quelque chose à
l'un de vos chroniqueurs non bonjour
nous et non sur un a volé je vous
l'avais déjà détecteur de mensonges et
non pas du tout de risque et pour
l'instant je suis honnête n'a pas dit si
ça vous avez joué toute façon devant vos
téléspectateurs quatrième question avez
vous déjà porté les mêmes sous vêtements
plusieurs jours de suite sans nom
bonjour beinheim icaunais importés sous
votre jeans pas franchement au point
qu'elle se trouve je crois que la
cuillère non tu leur de mensonge non par
choix merci alors passer aux questions
un peu plus intéressantes à me laisser
pas moi qui ai fait les questions
ouais c'est bon on le voit avez vous
déjà
je n'aime pas dire ce mot avez vous déjà
lâché xxs caisse voilà un pay pwyp et
accuser quelqu'un d'autre ça c'est le
questionnaire de castel d'autres
questions dont vous non non mais c'est
ce processionnaires live et android
allez c'est vous le chef c'est vous qui
décidez est-ce que vous avez déjà songé
à virer une personne qui est autour de
cette table
oui mais voilà oui avec qui j'ai parlé
non à ben ils sont plusieurs à allonger
bonne
tous sans exception oui à un moment
c'est exigeant mais qui traverse
l'esprit mais aussi l'on pensait de
vieira en provence
ils exigent c'est vrai que si on répond
pas mais ils sont restés c'est
formidable bravo bravo merci vous
question suivante la numéro 7 chiffre
magique
cyril
êtes vous un bon coup au lycée qui
vérifier ça s'explique mal mais bon
d'après vous aux rédacteurs en chef ou
les films à petit a créé oui oui oui ou
noir et rouge ou non mais tu sens un oui
oui je n'ai pas de zz c'est mon choix en
parler je n'ai pas dit oui si la reprise
sera bien voilà merci ben ouais pas
xilam et posez lui la question est ce
que vous avez ainsi dit ah bah oui mais
à chaque fois de se reposer 15 dernière
question vous voulez poser de questions
on peut arriver à lisible une question
vous allez lui poser question alors moi
je veux poser une question est ce que on
entend beaucoup de ces derniers temps
est ce que vous vous rapprochez de plus
en plus du groupe m6 ou w9 rescue gère à
les mélanger à main à ses yeux braqués
sur moi c'est la question écrit sur
facebook mais ces deux grosses rumeurs
franchement que tp va s'en aller là bas
ma race pas t'es belle puissance et la
personne va partir tout seul on
répondait alors la personne sinon
à
[Applaudissements]
/
proposer une 4 puisque le détecteur de
mensonges bien de dire que vous avez
menti et que donc vous ignorez
improbable rapprochement avec le groupe
m6 est ce que si vous allez dans le
groupe m6 vous partirez avec l'équipe
pas tous oui
mais khatami
y at il un autre groupe m6 vous à
approcher du temps jusqu'aux en disant
il ya eu déjà des dizaines de
chroniqueuse c'est ce que vous en avez
déjà secrètement qui fait une de ses
marges et une question non
[Applaudissements]
elle est démontrée
vous avez eu un rapport sexuel il ya
moins de 24 heures alice fait partie de
la famille non visible la 10e et
dernière question que dernière question
de personnes c'est bon et bien 48 heures
alors quel est votre question avez vous
eu un rapport sexuel il eut à moins de
48 heures non
non ils adorent ça ne trompe pas sur
cette machine
c'est bon c'est tout j'aime bien cette
séquence question avez vous déjà eu un
rapport sexuel ont déjà eu un rapport
sexuel dans votre carrière avec une
collaboratrice adam carrière au carrière
d'animatrice couteau
collaboratrice animatrice qu'est ce
qu'un dans l'art du parlement du paf où
une chroniqueuse
une personne connue non s'est concentré
de ouf
marchand j'adore
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
chez moi
merci